ils étaient 5000 selon les organisateurs
et près de 2000 selon la préfecture du
rhône des manifestants décidés à défier
la droite ultra-conservatrice là où
l'association génération identitaire
aujourd'hui dissoute avait domicilié son
siège national a lieu qui n'a donc pas
été choisis au hasard par les
organisateurs de la mobilisation de part
la présence de cette droite radicale en
plein coeur de la ville des lumières
c'est devenu très compliqué sur lyon en
fait les violences de l'extrême droite
ça date de des années ça n'a pas été
réglé honni au niveau médiatique au
niveau politique à lyon il faut savoir
que nous savons quand même une terre
fertile par rapport à la montée des
violences de l'extrême droite et donc
nous sommes là pour dénoncer tout cela
est pur voilà se montrer dans la rue
pour dire stop également alerté tous les
la préfecture entre autres puisque les
locaux de l'extrême droite tout à mon
identité j'ai deux générations qui se
sont ouverts il n'ya pas longtemps alors
que nous nous avons demandé la fermeture
de ses locaux nous avons quand même
relativement nombreuses et nombreux pour
dire stop et arrêter de cette montée
d'extrême droite de façon à ce que
possible mais derrière la situation
lyonnaise c'est un message politique
nationale que certains élus au sein du
cortège ont souhaité faire passer un cri
d' alerte à la gauche dans une période
où les derniers sondages au tour de
l'élection présidentielle lui sont
extrêmement défavorable mais surtout
mettre collectivement la candidate
déclaré marine le pen et le candidat
putatif eric zemmour à plus de 30% des
intentions de vote alors pas question de
l'art abandonner une once de terrain
malheureusement c'est pas seulement à
lyon c'est à dire all your ya peut-être
des idées des histoires liées à la cahc
la création de génération identitaire
mais ce qu'on observe c'est que d'un
côté il ya une extrême droite isation du
paysage politico-médiatique
capac zemmour malheureusement il ya plus
d'eau plus de gens qui suit ça et
l'autre côté c'est classique vous avez
des groupuscules ultra violents qui sont
là pour intimider et m'être imposé
laurent dans la rue
il faut lutter contre les deux faut
lutter à la fois contre la propagande
raciste et fasciste à la télé par des
gens qui ont pignon sur rue et dire
montrer à ces groupuscules qu on les
craint pas qu'on est là mad manière
massive pacifique unitaire je crois que
c'est c'est le bea bail minimum déjà
qu'on puisse faire appel entendu par le
cortège malgré quelques invectives aucun
incident n'a été déploré entre
manifestants anti extrême droite et
d'autres vies densifier comme faisant
partie de la mouvance identitaire reste
à savoir si le message au reste de la
gauche sera lui aussi entendu